- So when I said that Mike
Flynn was back in the news
and his advocating for a military coup
in the United States was likely protected
by the First Amendment.
Many people said but wait a minute
but what about the fact
that he is a former
military officer
couldn't he be punished
under the Uniform Code
of Military Justice?
And the answer is maybe, but
he probably should not be.
First of all yes is possible
for retired military officers
to be punished under the Uniform
Code of Military Justice.
But it's unlikely that those
laws are going to withstand
First Amendment scrutiny.
It's actually an issue that
is currently on appeal.
Law professor Steve Vladeck
is heading the charge
to try and overturn the
current case law on this
and they stand a good
chance of succeeding.
So this is one of those cases
where under current law,
it might theoretically be possible.
But if that was ever challenged
and went up to the Supreme Court
there's a good chance of
that might be overruled.
So we will in fact see
this issue in court.